last year I moved to Iowa to help build
a grassroots presidential campaign as
the campaign took off the question came
up over and over again how are we gonna
get this agenda to Congress this is my
answer so join the movement and let's
fix the system together that was
Jonathan Herzog a former top staffer on
Democratic presidential candidate Andrew
Yang's presidential campaign and now
he's formally announced since he left
the campaign a bit of his own to unseat
House Judiciary Committee Chairman Jerry
Nadler in New York's 10th congressional
district joining me now for an Ingram
angle exclusive is Jonathan Herzog hey I
I appreciate respect anybody who's
willing to throw their hat in the ring
and thinks that they can do something
better especially against the long term
incumbent by the way I took on somebody
in my party who had been in there for 14
years and I beat him so it can be done
with even a small amount of money your
platform though I got to tell you is
when I look at it my freedom dividend
Medicare for all this democracy dollars
that you call is that really what it
takes in order to win in New York's 10th
district well thank you for having me
and the reason I'm running on this
platform is we're going through a
fundamental economic shift the greatest
in our history where we're automating
away the most common jobs in our economy
working in retail is still the most
common job and so we need to enact
meaningful solutions to help hundreds of
thousands of folks here in New York and
especially in a tenth district to
transition through this fundamental
economic shift so how do you beat Jerry
Nadler he's been there for a long time
he's a powerful Judiciary Committee
Chairman how do you actually beat an
incumbent like that in New York City
well so it starts with proposing bold
solutions that address the central
challenges of our time again if you have
a trillion dollar tech company like
Amazon let's say paying zero in federal
taxes then certainly we need to look up
and say we need to pass a freedom
dividend of $1,000 a month to put it
into the hands put economic resources
directly into the hands
of New Yorkers and so putting forth bold
solutions that address the challenges of
our time is what will bring us across
the finish line
now that Jonathan a are you following in
a Oasys footsteps in saying Amazon don't
come to New York we don't want you here
well certainly we have to embrace
technology and progress and all the
great innovations that are that are
coming our way
come on Jonathan do you want it do you
want Amazon to come to New York yes or
no look we we are pro-jobs yes no
question look yes it it is good to have
dropped growths and obviously we just
here in the state
a you'll see was wrong look we have to
focus on the fact that if you go to the
Amazon go store for example in
Brookfield in our district Jonathan
garrison I do this for a living you're
gonna get a lot of it if you're running
for race it was a OC wrong or right look
our focus is on making sure that the
tens of millions of folks who work right
now in retail have a meaningful path
forward in a transition and right here
in the 10th district we've lost 10,000
retail jobs over the last number of
years and so we have to focus on the
problems on the ground facing New Yorker
ISM we have a mindset of economic and
social insecurity and we have to put
resources into our hands to help us move
forward well I listen I appreciate it I
think you have a map you are your
Harvard law you're very accomplished I
love that you have passion for for the
you know for being involved in helping
out in a presidential campaign we need
good people on both sides of the aisle
the only thing I challenge you with and
I won't give you enough time to answer
unfortunately is I think why you did
well at Harvard Law maybe not so good in
math because giving 250 million people
adults $1,000 a month doesn't adds up to
trillions of dollars I think three
trillion dollars a year I don't know how
you get from here to there I'll give you
20 seconds before we wrap up so the
headline cost is much lower but really
again we have to ask the question we
have to look up how is it that if
trillion dollar companies are paying
zero in taxes less than you and I this
is the this is the key challenge there's
a reason for that will do that tax thing
I got a wrap up here good luck you're
running against Jerry Dada ler so we are
rooting for you it's
for you